hello welcome I'm Karen Rothman I'm the
associate director of public humanities
and I work with Matt Jacobson and Laura
Wexler who are the directors of public
humanities and this before I introduce
Emily Barnard I just want to tell you
just briefly that this is part of the
democracy in America series of talks and
we have talks here and at Yale and at
the Ives branch of the New Haven Public
Library so I hope that you'll come to as
many events as you can if you want to
subscribe to our newsletter just right
subscribe to public humanities at
yale.edu or ask me afterwards give me
your name afterwards our next library
talk is up the ice branch on February
4th a talk called race and the new
right-wing politics of precarity it'll
be a really good talk with Daniel who
was saying in John Joe loans so I want
to thank the library because this is a
series that we really love at both at
the Wilson branch in the Ives branch
Luis Chavez Brunel the branch manager
Marian Huggins who runs the urban life
experience book discussion series I
think there's some members of that
series here today on January 11th and
the 13th the subject was Emilie Bernards
new book Black is the body and I also
want to thank South Godfrey who's the
manager of reference and adult learning
at the New Haven Public Library because
he's helped us set this event up so now
to our speaker Emily Barnard is the
Julian and Lindsay green and gold
professor of English at the University
of Vermont she teaches courses in
critical race and ethnic studies she
holds a BA and a PhD in American Studies
from Yale University she's published
many books and essays including remember
me to Harlem the letters of Langston
Hughes and Carl Van Vechten
which was a New York Times notable book
of the year and if you haven't read it I
recommend it so highly I taught parts of
it last year and my students absolutely
love this book also some of my best
friends writers on in terrain
a friendship which was a notable book by
the New York Public Library and Michelle
Obama the first lady in photographs
which received a 2010 NAACP Image Award
for outstanding literary work in 2012
her book Carl Van Vechten and the Harlem
Renaissance a portrait in black and
white was published by Yale University
Press and she also provided an amazing
intro to nella Larsen sneh Bella passing
for the Penguin Classics series her
essays have been featured in best
American Essays and best
african-american essays and best
creative nonfiction in new republic in
american scholar in the boston globe and
the book she'll be speaking about and
reading from tonight which is called
black as the body stories from my
grandmother's time my mother's time and
mine was published last year by Knopf to
stellar reviews and much acclaim I also
should mention that it was the very best
day of reading of my year 2019 I spent
the day on my couch reading this book
and just it was a complete pleasure the
book was featured on Oprah coms 25 books
we can't wait for it received multiple
printings and it's now in paperback you
can read more about emily Barnard at
Emily Barnard calm which I recommend and
lastly I guess I wanted to say that
we've been looking forward to this event
since July when we planned it and I've
been worried since July that it was
going to snow today so I want to thank
the weather it's cold but it's not
snowing thank you so much
[Applause]
hi everybody can you hear me I'm gonna
project like thusly and I want to thank
Karen for that wonderful introduction
thank you so much it's it really is
homecoming and it great to see so many
friends michael moran at the by Nikki
it's so great to see you so this is a
delight for me and I am honored to be
invited Karen and also Marian for making
this possible Mac Jacobson so thank all
of you think to you for coming out I
want to take you on a little journey
through this book if you don't mind and
we have some time then for discussion
afterward I'm going to start at the
beginning which is aptly titled
beginnings this book was conceived in a
hospital it was 2001 and I was
recovering from surgery on my lower
bowel which had been damaged in a
stabbing a friend a writer came to visit
me in the hospital and suggested not
only that there was a story to be told
about the violence I had survived but
also that my body itself was trying to
tell me something which was that it was
time to face down the fear that had kept
me from telling the story of the
stabbing as well as other stories I
needed to tell I began to write essays
the first one I published was teaching
the inward over the next few years more
essays followed along with several
attempts to write about the stabbing
I couldn't tell that story yet because I
didn't know what it meant it took seven
more years for me to understand that the
experience of being at the wrong end of
a hunting knife was only the situation
not the story itself it was a stage not
the drama in the situation and the story
the art of personal narrative Vivian
Zbornak writes the situation is a
context or circumstance sometimes the
plot the story is the emotional
experience that preoccupies the writer
the insight the wisdom the thing one has
come to say
the setting of scar tissue which is the
essay I eventually wrote about being
stabbed is my gut the blood let flow by
the knife is a trail I followed until I
discovered the story which is the
mystery of storytelling itself and how
hard it is to tell the whole truth each
essay is anchored in this mystery in
blood
they are also rooted in contradictions
primary among them being that the
stabbing unleashed the storyteller in
may in more than one way that bizarre
act of violence set me free but of
course the stabbing has been a source of
misery as well as opportunity for
instance I suffered from recurrent
excruciating stomach pain for many years
before another trip to the hospital
revealed that I had developed adhesions
in my bowel the surgeon was able to
untangle my intestines and scar tissue
but he warned me that the adhesions
would return there was nothing I could
do to prevent or predict them you're
just unlucky
he said sympathetically the pain he
assured me would be random and severe it
did return Thunder again throughout my
body and sent me back to the hospital
where a third surgeon seated to the
inherent malady of the mystery and
confessed that medicine was more art
than science the gift of his honesty was
to me as valuable as any solution would
have been once I accepted the randomness
of the situation in my bowel life took
on a new urgency and so did the desire
to understand it
I turned to art over science story over
solution I found a voice the book
imagined in 2001 began to take shape in
a need to know to explore to understand
before it was too late
insofar as a personal essay is the best
an attempt to grasp the mysteries of
life the form made sense to me on a
visceral level the need to understand in
fact was what it engendered the stabbing
in the first place
I met the knife head on something in me
just needed to know each essay in this
book was born in a struggle to find a
language that would capture the totality
of my experience as a woman a black
American a writer teacher mother wife
and daughter I wanted to discover a new
way of telling I wanted to tell the
truth about life as I have lived it
that desire evolved into this collection
which includes a story about adoption
that is as pragmatic as it is romantic a
portrait of an interracial marriage that
is absent of hand-wringing and a journey
into the n-word that includes as much
hemp humor as grief these stories grew
into an entire book meant to contribute
something to the American racial drama
besides the endearing narrative of black
innocence and white guilt that
particular narrative is not false of
course which accounts for its endurance
but there are other true stories to tell
stories steeped in defiance of popular
assumptions about race whose contours
are shaped by inez with conventional
discussions about race relations these
other true stories I needed to explore
but I was mainly driven by a need to
engage in what Zora Neale Hurston calls
the oldest human longing self-revelation
the only way I knew how to do this was
by letting the blood flow I'm following
the trail of my own ambivalence I was
not stabbed because I was black but I've
always viewed the violence I survived as
a metaphor for the violent encounter
that has generally characterized
American race relations the man who
stabbed me was white
but more meaningful to me that his skin
was a look in his eyes which were vacant
of emotion there is no connection
between us no common sphere yet we were
suddenly and irreparable bound by a
knife an attachment that cost us both
him his freedom made my wholeness
revisiting that wound has been a way of
putting myself back together the
equation of writing and regeneration is
fundamental in black American experience
so if race was not an essential factor
and what brought me into contact with a
hunting knife I've certainly treated the
wound with the salve I inherited from
people whose experiences of blackness
has shaped their lives as fully and
poetically as it is shaped mine
blackness is an art not a science it is
a paradox intangible and visceral a
situation and a story it is a thread
that connects these essays but its
significance as an experience emerges
sometimes randomly and unpredictably in
life as I have lived it it is
inconsistent continuously in flux and
get also a constant condition that I
carry in and on my body it is good it is
a condition that encompasses beauty
misery wonder and opportunity in its
inherent contradictions utter mysteries
and bottomless Ness as a reservoir of
narratives race is a story of my life
and therefore black is the body of this
book
I always forget to include the trigger
warning when I write the first you know
pages of this book some of you and here
intimately experiment with the
experience I write about the stabbing
the story that used as a frame of this
book took place in New Haven it was
August 7th 1994 and a man who was a
paranoid schizophrenic and off of his
medication as simple as that came in to
coffee in it was on Audubon Street and
that's the beginning of the story
including at the beginning because I was
thinking a lot about Toni Morrison which
she wrote about The Bluest Eye and how
the point of the book was not the trauma
of what happened to piccola Breedlove
but it was the why of the whole thing
you know and the story of the stabbing
is to me something I've been wrestling
with and as I've grown as a human being
as a writer and a teacher I was
interested in the way the story defined
me and has to find me beyond my own
power and my intentions I'm gonna be a
little bit from that essay
on the night of August 7th 1994 I walked
into a coffee shop called coffee on
Audubon Street in New Haven I was a
graduate student in the American Studies
Program and I was there to work
I had James Weldon Johnson with me
specifically his 1912 novel the
autobiography of an ex-colored man about
which I was writing a paper I was having
a hard time concentrating that night so
I went to coffee which was not far from
where I lived and was one of the many
spaces in New Haven where student
students went to read and write and talk
it was a typical coffee shop in a
typical college town I was frustrated
with my work so frustrated with my
inability to concentrate that I was
giving the evening only one last chance
it was late nearly 9 o'clock maybe too
late maybe call it a night I debated
with myself walking slowly the three
yards from my car
to the door of coffee I was probably
talking to myself as I do all the time
muttering about all that I had to do a
man on a bicycle and I approached the
door at the same time beside him stood
an average size average looking brown
dog on a leash
the man was listening on his bike
rocking side to side as if he himself
had not made the commitment to go inside
the shop maybe maybe not our eyes met he
looked like Gallagher the 1970s comedian
the same long hair and bald pate the
same thickness - or at least that's what
I remember
to this day when I think of Daniel Silva
I think of Gallagher whom I rarely if
ever thought about before that night I
don't remember who went in first but I
remember making the decision not to let
the oddness of this stranger bother me
because he was odd it was a way he was
listing on his bicycle
it was the unsettling way he looked at
me his look was familiar
or to aware not the passing glance of a
stranger even now I have a hard time
describing it
he was odd it was instinct I knew
something was wrong with him
or maybe this is just the cliche of
hindsight speaking after all we're
talking about a university town and a
coffee shop full of nerds offer their
own little worlds people who routinely
talk to themselves out loud as I had
been doing that night
here I've lingered longer than I
lingered in that moment which passed as
quickly as a proverbial blink of an eye
I looked at the man made a quick
unconscious association with Gallagher
went in to get my coffee and planted
myself at a table I put my keys on the
table I pulled out my book and notepad I
took off my glasses and my watch no
distractions just me and the page as
naked as I allow myself to get in public
at some point I looked up and noticed
that the strange man had settled into a
chair not far from me I was aware of him
as he watched a table full of young
girls next to me presumably
undergraduates they were talking about a
sexual encounter one of them had had
recently the girls were loud sexy and
full of swagger
I even feeling annoyed by them and their
devil-may-care bluster but now I looked
up and saw that the man was staring at
them obviously and apparently
salaciously I felt intimidated by his
frank stare but I looked at the girls
and they didn't seem to care which made
me proud of them and emboldened for
myself go ahead talk about sex I thought
don't let this freak scare you
eventually the girls left when they did
the man turned his attention to a young
woman I imagined to be a medical student
or a law student judging from the size
of her very official looking textbooks
she tried to engage him in conversation
she said something like hi I didn't hear
his response but I do know that not long
after this exchange the woman gathered
up her books and left
what happened next here's what I told
detective C Willoughby at 1:30 a.m. on
August 8th 1994 this detective then
spoke with blank who stated that she was
sitting inside the restaurant when a
white male came in who had a dog
she then stated that he walked the dog
outside and then returned he then pulled
out a knife and started stabbing people
she stated that he stabbed her once in
the stomach and that she then fled the
restaurant she stated that she had never
seen the white male subject before and
she does not know him
I remember stillness the hum of low
voices and the lights bright yet
soothing like the talk surrounding me
people talking and laughing quietly
students professors writers I was the
only black person present but these were
people just like me who looked like me
so many moments like these over the
years in coffee shops in so many cities
all forgettable ordinary and uneventful
but these particular moments on this
particular evening stay with me more
palpable more probably than any other
moments from that long night the
stillness the quiet the hum of low
Pleasant talk the sensation of being
inside of those moments it is the only
real memory I retain from that night yet
just beyond the borders of that quiet
Pleasant memory I can still hear the
rhythmic continuous sound of a dog
barking outside like a warning
suddenly chaos pandemonium bedlam
topsy-turvy
madhouse a holy mess
all hell broke loose the moon the room
turned upside down on its back inside
out went crazy flipped out other words
other cliches fear erupted like a
seismic shift in the Earth's surface and
then charged and pierced and saturated
the room like smoke fear a good friend
to me that night chased me toward the
back door but even in the midst of this
utter confusion I paused and listened
for gunshots this was America after all
I paused not only to listen for the
gunshots but to brace myself literally
tense my shoulders gripped my teeth and
searched inside somewhere for the pain
the tearing impact of a bullet when I
completely completed that brief
inventory and discovered no bullet I was
overcome by feeling of relief hope luck
a chance and a door right behind me and
I ran and then I was outside in the back
of the coffee house there were no lights
it was as dark as the bottom of a pocket
others rushed by me I don't remember if
they were speaking shouting screaming or
crying what I remember is silence which
seemed inexplicable to me even then I
would find out later that what occasion
that queer silence was adrenaline
pounding in my ears and deafening me I
don't know how long I watched others
rush past me before I walked back toward
the coffee shop I don't remember how
long I stood there trying to understand
before everything in me rejected what I
saw and I charged back into the shop to
retrieve my watch my keys and glasses so
that I could drive home why did I do
this it doesn't make any sense but
however I try to explain it my stubborn
West Indian heritage a Freudian state of
denial the same thing happened next
I found myself face-to-face with the odd
man and he had a knife in his hand at
this point the knife would have been
covered in blood I don't remember the
blood
I do remember asking him not to kill me
I meant it of course but at the same
time it just seemed like the thing to
say I felt I was playing a role I felt
that the die was cast I had turned and
met my fate but I was watching as much
as I was experiencing my witnessing was
involuntary in the autobiography of an
ex-colored man the anonymous narrator
recalls being fixed to the spot while he
watches a white mob lynch a black man
like the narrator I was fixed to the
spot why I did not move because I did
not want to excite this man I did not
move because I had to see what was going
to happen next I did not move because I
was afraid I did not move because I was
free from fear as many report feeling in
the moments before death I did not move
because I knew that he would hurt me if
I did I did not move because I knew he
would not kill me
I did not move because I didn't believe
he had the knife I saw in front of me I
did not move because I did not know what
to do maybe all of the above maybe none
maybe some combination I will never know
for sure I was more afraid of being in
the dark without my eyeglasses than I
was of running into the man with a knife
again I had I've been wearing eyeglasses
since I was eight years old the last
time I had gone without my glasses in
public I was not allowed to walk down a
street without holding the hand of an
adult I had never been on a city street
alone without my glasses I was on the
eve of my
27th birthday when I was stabbed the
last time I had been out in public
without my glasses
I was not permitted to be awake at 10:24
which is the time it has become at this
point in the story a figure ran toward
me a man I was afraid I stopped
he must have seen my fear this man
because he waved his hands in the air
and shouted I'm a Good Samaritan a Good
Samaritan I trusted his words and his
biblical reference and let him lead me
to some steps across the street this is
from officer pitoni axe incident report
composed at 20 to 24 on August 7th 1994
this investigating officer did find one
white male subject and one black female
subject on the stairs of an apartment
complex located across the street from
24 Whitney Avenue both subjects had stab
wounds to the stomach areas and were
bleeding profusely due to the extent of
the injuries and calling for medical
assistance this officer was not able to
obtain any information identification of
the victims what's your name what's your
social security number I fired these
questions at the white male subject
shortly before officer Pitonyak arrived
the young white man who I had never seen
before was sitting on the steps a few
feet away from me he was going into
shock and I was trying to keep him from
doing so I kept up my round of
questioning and he mumbled some answers
I'm going out I'm going out he said and
fainted it was only then that I really
looked at him he's white as a sheet I
thought literally white as a sheet this
is what it looks like the young white
man had pale skin light blond hair and
wore white oxford shirt the contrast
between the blood and his skin hair and
shirt must have been dramatic but I
don't remember the
blood I watched him the more he faded
away the less able I was to ignore what
was happening just under my hand an EMT
came close to me and asked about the
young man and I answered him I talked
and talked
told my story posed as a witness even as
I was seeing sparks and hearing static
and the EMTs badge started to blur
trained to recognize the signs of shock
the EMT cradled my head and took my hand
away from my side his gloved hand like
my bare hand became wet with blood he
said something to his partner who was
tending to the white male subject
suddenly there was a commotion around me
he laid me down carefully on the steps
he held my bloody hand and his team
moved me onto a gurney at some point our
eyes met and we laughed the more I
laughed the more I came to the more I
laughed the more my wound gaped open
which made us laugh even harder it was
also absurd the same EMT came to visit
me in the hospital before I went into
surgery
he seems Shawn burr somber and shaken
watching him look at me I realized that
my situation was dire I tried to mirror
his grave expression and warn myself
that getting stabbed was serious
business but I wanted to laugh with him
again the incident still seemed mostly
ridiculous I'll leave it there as I said
that that the whole experience um has
shaped a lot of my adult life and not
just because of the obvious drama of it
but also because as I said in the
introduction I have had to keep making
visits back to the hospital because of
adhesions for a while they were happy
and have being at seven year intervals
there's something really covered
comforting about the biblical
significance there are all these sevens
in the story was 27 it was like a
seventh and so when once we hit the
8-year mark my husband and I thought
okay we really nailed it
thing you know we were and I and I but
then I turned my book in actually a few
months before it from my book in and yet
again and I was so sure it wasn't
adhesions I actually successfully talked
my surgeon and convinced him that I
thought my appendix had burst this is
you know many memorable moment and
storytelling I think it was really
there's a confuse but I was sure my
appendix had burst that no more
adhesions but I learned a valuable
lesson of course about the power of
narrative or lack thereof but also
there's something as I started to
research to write this story just
encountering myself in hospital records
newspaper reports and police records as
a black female subject and thinking
about representation and how often black
people are reduced to these descriptors
and there's something about me I think
that just needed to put flesh on the
skeleton of the idea of this black
female subject and tell the story but
there are many versions of this incident
in fact boo Shapiro who is an amazing
journalist has a piece called one
violent crime it's a different
perspective on what happened but it
happened to both of us I like to think
of myself as having inherited something
from the literary ancestors that I hold
dear and I'm sure many of you hold dear
in this room the power of language I
gave a talk recently and a young man
asked me some you ever feel that you
need to hide your blackness never feel
you have to throw up screens depending
on your social circumstances of course
the answer is yes but I'm black all the
time I told him I'm black when I'm
walking my dog in the woods of Vermont
and I'm black when I'm giving lectures
on african-american literature and
discussing the nature of American racial
identity I'm black when I'm writing
about race and black when I'm not
writing about race
I'm always a black writer and I'm always
telling black stories in an essay on
this in this book I talk about the
experience of learning at a young age
that about the limits of narrative when
it comes to black experience I spent so
many years determined not to be a
consequence of history and believing
that I could invent my own story but as
I write in the book that was before I
understood that the drive to create a
new story for oneself is the oldest
black story there is I am a black writer
I care about literary legacy and
inheritance about the body of work but
even more I care about the shape of a
story I like lines gaps blank spaces all
of the things that can't be captured in
language the form is a story and the
story is in the form these are lines
from an essay that actually came out
today from the Yale Review called
stereopticon and I think the same
question animates that essay in the book
just how do we know what we know and how
do we tell stories from what perspective
or stories authentic my book is about
being a mother and a daughter as much as
anything else it is a record of what
I've learned and what I'm learning as
I'm parenting now teenage girls yes 13
it's just a joy everyday we laugh and
hug so please let me to read a little
bit from the title story black as the
body black history my brown daughter's
were becoming black when they were 6
years old they were watching television
one day in February Black History Month
a commercial came on it was more like a
30-second history lesson a commemoration
of a pilot a poet or a politician
a first black as a writer I know calls
them them being the racial pioneers the
inaugural Negroes the foremost
african-americans to break through
racial barriers in their chosen fields
by break through I mean of course secure
the regard of white people see we're
black Julia said to Isabella no we're
brown Isabella responded
yeah but they call it black Julia
explained I thought it was great
then I thought that was wonderful
and I have to say I'm jumping again a
little bit but it was in that exchange I
said okay there's a book here somewhere
you know this that kernel of that this
is fascinating despite my efforts to
shield them my daughters had somehow
gotten wise to the absurd and illogical
nature of American racial identity
blackness Julia had figured out had
nothing to do with actual skin color
blackness she had come to understand was
an external identity external to her
anyway race was something other people
identified something they said but not
necessarily saw blackness she had
intuited was a social category not a
color but a condition and like it or not
it was time she was informing her sister
to get with the proverbial program in
spite of me but also because of me my
brown daughter's were becoming black my
heart sank it was not blackness per se
that caused my heart to sink
I enjoy being black but it took me a
long time to get here to this place of
racial pleasure my earliest experiences
of blackness were defined by an
unpleasant and uncomfortable
hyper-vigilance
being black meant that you had to be
constantly aware that you could never
really be at ease
early on I got wise to the fact that
being black in a white place meant that
the world
not a safe place not for you in my
family race was not a construction or a
theory or an outdated consequence of
history but the active living foundation
of our reality race determined the
contours of every choice we made every
Monday in public act we performed was a
project with a name when we moved into
our house it was called integration when
my older brother and I entered the
public school system it's called
desegregation the split between black
and white was not metaphorical railroad
tracks divided black and white Nashville
on the white side of town south
Nashville we played a role in a grand
project of enormous proportions we lived
in South Nashville but a North Nashville
we could be black in a way that was not
possible in any other part of the city
in North Nashville no one white was
watching we could relax we were free
North Nashville was where my father
practiced medicine
and will reiative ents at Fisk
University my parents alma mater and one
of this country's oldest HBCUs North
Nashville was where we attended church
in a small chapel that was established
for the faculty and students of Meharry
Medical College from which both of my
parents received their graduate degrees
among the parishioners in the chapel
were men and women I called aunt and
uncle even though we had no biological
relationship we shared something bigger
and more profound than blood history
inside the church we celebrated our
belief in God and a common pride and how
we all made it over and broke through we
work a community a black community built
in spite and because of racism
because if it had not been for white
supremacy schools like Fisk and mihari
might never have existed but my
daughter's were not born under the
shadow of this history they are black by
ideology and affinity but not by blood
when they were 12 months old they
assumed dual citizenship in both America
at African America once when we were out
of town visiting my husband's extended
family I told them the Black History
Month story I tried to explain my
reasons for having to wanted to protect
my daughters from the language of race
but my explanation seemed only to make
them impatient don't you want them to
know their history John's cousin asked I
should say my husband's he's
italian-american he's white I knew what
she meant she meant American slavery
segregation and the civil rights
movement Frederick Douglass Sojourner
Truth and Rosa Parks
Martin Malcolm and other first blacks
February stories which as American
stories belong to her this white
American woman more than they do to my
daughter's I am an African who lives in
America Isabella explained one day she
was recounting a conversation she had
had with a 3rd grade classmate the
African children's choir had come to
Burlington and the class had taken a
field trip to see them perform later
that day Isabella's classmate in an
attempt to identify the difference she
perceived between Isabella and the
children on stage had referred to
Isabella as an african-american Isabella
corrected her while the law may state
that I am an American I am African when
I came to this country she continued
astonishment made it difficult for me to
continue paying attention that my
daughter had such a fine sense of her
place in the world I had not known her
implicit assessment of my role as
essentially a porter in the stage of her
life journey felt wholly appropriate I
just I was just carrying the bags
apparently my daughters and I flipped
through picture books of 12th century
Ethiopian underground churches carved
out of rock I showed them websites that
feature both centuries old drawings and
modern photographs of Ethiopian kings
and queens yours is the only African
country to fight off the colonizer I
remind them often every mother thinks
her daughters look like angels but my
daughters do resemble the doe-eyed halo
drown cherubs that dominate Ethiopian
Orthodox Christian iconography why did
why people make black people slaves
Isabella asked one February afternoon
there's been slavery all over the world
I told her even in Ethiopia I'm proud
that my daughter's were born in a world
were not only slaves but angels and
aristocrats look like them my daughters
get older it's fascinating to watch them
create their identities the other night
Julia texted me from a party she told a
close friend of hers that she was
Italian and the friend rejected this and
I said you're the author of your
identity and you tell this boy that if
he understands a mystery of identity I'd
like to hear I'd like to hear that
because it's still a mystery to many of
us and I told her she was free to invent
her own her own name I went to
read a little bit from the story I wrote
about the essay I wrote about and they
keep making a family the four of us and
of course my story here is going to be
radically different from theirs so I can
only attest to my own experience so at
this point we my husband and I are in on
the trek to the family's home and I
think everything else is pretty
self-evident
we drive slowly as the road thins and
the disappears as if it had surrendered
to the commanding natural landscape
around us
Helen our american ethiopia adoption
agent had told us the road would end and
we would have to walk for an hour to
meet the girls and their family marjorie
another adoption agent dismissed this
information as another one of Helens
fantastic stories Gera pulls a car to a
gentle stop among small bunches of
beavertail cactus with stems as wide and
flat as paddles and decorated with
bristles like stubble on a man's face
there are only three yards between us
but the men's voices sound tinny and
faraway underneath my feet the earth is
as light and packed as brown sugar
within arm's reach as a small island of
green bordered by a layer of rocks in
its centre stands a tree with a thin
trunk and a flowering crown like a tall
skinny kid with an afro in the distance
more trees some dense and willowy stand
in line on stand in a line on faded
cracked earth the sky is thick with all
the blue left in the world
I nearly trip on Titanic pieces of shale
my boots catch in the valley of
crevasses between them the Sun quickly
discovers a skin beneath my hair hat and
the rest of my clothing I feel its
piercing impact in my joints and lungs
as we approach a group of thatched huts
topped with perfect cylinders of green
long grass my heart beats so rapidly
that I reflexively cover it with my hand
i smooth my shirt and adjust my hat I
hope I look like what the family wants
for their twins as we are greeted by the
people to whom the girls belong I
imagine a woman being presented to a
groom at the inauguration of an arranged
marriage be prepared to be treated like
royalty Helen had written in an
unusually helpful email indeed the
girl's family has slaughtered a sheep in
our honor a large platter of the roasted
sheep meat sits on a clay table the loaf
of bread we bought an eddy grat is
placed on the side everyone gathers to
eat but after a few token bites I sit
back on a bench molded from the same
clay as a table and walls of the wide
circular room I try to arrange my
features into an expression that
communicates my appreciation for the
food my desire to enjoy it and my
inability to do so I am NOT successful
it is clear from the quality of the
murmurs Emily doesn't like it for hon
who says and smile sympathetically I can
tell he is trying to translate the
disappointment I have caused it is
terrible to know that I'm failing to
demonstrate the boundless depth of
gratitude I feel for everyone in this
room a torrent of emotion clogs my
throat my palms sweat and tingle I am
rigid with anticipation
eager for the wonderful terrible moment
in which the girls will be placed in our
arms beside me John eats heartily and
drinks sheep's milk from a tin cup
I cannot say no when the milk is offered
to me I feel multiple pairs of
interested eyes on me as I bring the cup
to my mouth
the twins grandmother brings out the
baby we will know as Isabella she is
wrapped in the same light blue quilted
outfit that she wears in a picture that
Helen sent months ago her grandmother a
slight woman with a lightly wrinkled
face stands in a space that separates
two rooms of the family home the sky
shines a moviestar light down on the two
of them
Isabella regards me dispassionately as
she takes in the entire scene julia
emerges mid whale she was afraid because
she has never seen white skin her hono
says and gently touches john's arm Julia
continues to cry as we stand outside the
compound and are presented with carrots
so bright and large they could serve as
props in a Bugs Bunny cartoon John
gathers us for a photograph before we
begin the trek back to the Land Rover
the return hike feels more arduous the
Sun hotter the air dryer I am trying not
to show my exhaustion the grandmother
has a swaddled as a Bella on her back
her steps are light and efficient on
veins of rock that protrude from the
earth I walk next to one of the babies
cousins a girl of 11 or 12
her eyes are large and kind the braids
in her hair shine she wears julia who
seems to be dozing on her back
underneath a cloth secured her faded
green dress we take learn we take turns
looking at each other and then looking
away before the other one catches us
there's so much I want to ask and tell
her but the membrane of language fine
and opaque at once travels with us like
a mobile glass partition even though it
feels a bit silly the next time I sense
her looking I meet her gaze and for the
second time today put my hand over my
heart
I pressed down hard when she looks away
she is still smiling you are a part of
our family now an older male cousin
tells us but that's it for goodbyes John
and I are hustled into the car whose
rumbling engine inspires more
caterwauling from Julia the babies are
shuffled around I hold julia who screams
and stares at me with tears cascading
from her eyes isabella
rests quietly in John's lap snug in the
nest of his arms and chest suddenly she
sits up and opens her mouth slightly
sheep's milk spills out of her tiny body
Julia follows suit before her second
round I take my hat and turn it upside
down under her chin three hours later we
we have become almost used to the smell
and the feeling of our daughter's vomit
caked on our clothing we are sticky with
heat and sweat and bodily fluids by the
time we arrive at the airport in Mecca
lay John leaves the girls with me while
he rushes to the bathroom to clean out
my hat and rinse Isabella's excretions
from his shirt with a baby tucked into
the crook of each arm I sink into a
plastic chair my dizziness and blurry
vision must be a result of the heat I
think an older woman wearing a black e
job says sound next to me she holds her
arms open I hand her Julia and she pulls
a small blanket from her belongings and
hands it to me she and John each take
one of my arms when it's
I'm too bored I still feel rickety as we
walked toward the plane but I have a
firm grip on Isabella who emerges from
the cloth on my shoulder as slowly as a
plant sprouting from the earth in a
time-lapse video she stretches her neck
like a periscope and pivots her head
slowly a certain look on her face like a
general assessing a battlefield or
Magellan surveying the Atlantic I think
and when she smiles I believe we are
sharing our first private joke julia has
decided that it is my particular job to
tend to her so John and I trade babies
once we are seated she and I fall asleep
quickly after takeoff a few minutes
later a wave of pain propels me out of
my seat and toward the bathroom along
the way I shove a miserable indignant
Julia into the arms of a pretty flight
attendant I am on my hands and knees in
the throes of studying seizing abdominal
pain when the attendant knocks on my
door
Hunt's on the door as soon as I undo the
latch she snatches the door open I look
up
she is stony I am perpendicular madam
your baby she sniffs presents me with
Julia who looks down at me with what
appears to be alarm on her 12 month old
face I have a lot of them I guess a lot
of stomach gut issues this book I
realize it but something that I'm you
know I one of my doctors said to me all
the all the mythology around the gut you
know and I had I actually had a position
who I was lucky to encounter a surgeon
who didn't like to cut and he was just
looked at me and he said I'm not gonna
this seems strange but it cut into you
and you look perfectly healthy and they
had he's you actually I was in New Haven
and everything untangled naturally and
and I said what made you not want to go
in and he said it was my gut instinct
anyway yes the book is the stories are
definitely etched inside of me in many
ways my daughters will never know my
mother and the book really belongs to my
mother who was a consummate storyteller
and inherit that inherited that trait
from many generations that came before
her they only have these stories of
course the story to tell them and the
stories that are in this book I'm still
learning the lessons of my mother's life
and one of the most instructive stories
that I have the pleasure and the honor
of carrying I discovered toward the end
of the book I'm gonna read a little bit
from that piece it's called my epilogue
called my turn a few years after my
mother died I discovered a cache of
papers she left in my childhood bedroom
closet she buried them in an act of
elegant and amusing symbolism underneath
a pile of my father's long forgotten
wrinkled shirts the papers consisted
mainly of poems drafts and drafts of
them but there are a few essays I hadn't
known she wrote essays one of them is an
utter autobiographical narrative about
her life as a child in the Jim Crow
South it's called my turn when my mother
was a child she often accompanied her
beloved grandmother mama Tempe to a
local grocery store in order to get to
the store they had to walk past rental
houses owned by a Lumber Company one day
some white boys threw rocks at the two
of them a pleasant stroll turned into a
nightmare my mother wrote mama Tempe who
practiced the kind of black stoicism
that has served as a guiding principle
for african-americans sin
the inception of African presence in
this country walked on without evincing
any motion while the white boys jeered
and pelted them with stones when my
mother asked mama tempie why the boys
where they were being treated that way
her grandmother told her that the boys
didn't know any better and should be
pitied
instead of hated my mother idolized mama
tempie she accepted her grandmother's
reasoning and as an adult went on to
practice the same kind of forbearance
that made mama tempie the embodiment of
strength and moral fortitude in the
poetry my mother wrote but the rock
still wounded she wrestled with the
wounds in my turn her grandmother's keen
analysis of the nature of racism that it
was a consequence of ignorance did not
stem the flow of blood that ran down her
leg after reading the story I knelt on
the floor my heart racing I reached the
final lines and then started all over
again
I was looking frantically for something
what was it I didn't know but I kept
scanning the lines over and over my
throat tight and my breath short there
was something I needed that I didn't see
what is it I kept asking myself as I
read the paragraphs again and again and
then searched through her other papers
looking and looking for what some words
to correct the abomination of the rocks
and my mother's bloodied leg and then I
realized that what I was looking for was
the salve an answer the end for while
the tale of how we suffer and how we are
delighted and how we may triumph is
never knew it must always be heard there
isn't any other tale to tell it's the
only light we've got in all this
darkness
James Baldwin explains it took me a
while it took the journey of this entire
book but I realized that there was a
lesson which was in every scar there is
a story the salve is a telling itself
thank you stop there
[Applause]
any comments or questions so many
friends here tonight thank you so much
for coming everybody
Nancy wonderful reading would you've
been talking about how your daughters
feel I love that you know you have
talked about this so many times and it's
a definitely an ongoing question it's
really different to write about three
year olds than 13 year olds go figure
so now we have to start our call all
kinds of bargains because it is it's a
different it's a different moment for
them as they start to yes invent their
own stories and have my daughter Julie
was like you're always embellishing
recently I thought you found me out
stories I heard a little flush to it
little drama with lighting but it still
still the emotional truth I tell her but
I was very applied to say I wrote an
essay called um what will your
daughter's think because I that question
is definitely with me the question how
are they going to use how are they going
to experience themselves now that people
have a hold of their lives in a
different kind of way I asked Julia once
I said what is this like and she said
well their stories about us it's not us
which I loved one because it gave me a
nice little out there you know but I
love that which was sort of did start to
think about it look these are
representations of us their stories from
our lives together
and my daughters are are definitely
storytellers they are learning to make
narratives you know from the stuff of
their lives and the book has been in
some ways another now vocabulary or set
of images that we now use to talk about
ourselves as a family so the book has
played that funny role is a product of
the stories I've lived with them at us
also helping us invent new stories I
think that question about writing other
people is something I'm always
interested in what you know to hear from
authors about how they navigate
that question and I wrote a recent story
actually the story that's up at the
yellow view now that has a scene a
problem a moment Julianne myself and it
was actually a moment when she asked me
she said you know I don't what you ever
read that about I said okay but you know
but we talked about the role that that
scene played in the essay and I think
that we came to an understanding about
those boundaries you know and and we
keep it having to understand them
differently as I get older but you know
I made a decision a while ago that I
think that I believe in the utility of
the stories that I tell anybody things
like that should come first you know and
I may be called into an office at some
point and be and I may be told that I
you know but this was actually not it
you know I may be on the therapists
couch hearing about how this is like
ruin their lives and I will pay that
price but at this point you know the
book feels like our book but as I move
into the next set of writings you know
as they develop their own private lives
you know I have to obviously respect
that but as I tell them if you leave
your diary in my office I'm gonna read
it and I mean I don't know if it's been
there I've seen that subconscious if
you're offering me this but it's a
constant way where I think we're
navigating and understanding you know
we'll see would be another essay is the
way they're shaping their identities in
part I guess in terms of our
understanding about about them now from
what they aren't saying to each other
and I guess I was curious about some of
the things that you left out of this
book and and how your sense of identity
is shaped both by what you do include
and
you don't know I like that a lot I
always you know I guess want to talk
about yeah I I the older I get the more
I feel I'm an educator you know by
profession but also by nature and this
book feels very real to me it's an
extension of my life in the classroom
you know I live in the books that I
teach
they're so central even guideposts for
me as I've grown learning how to live
from James Bolton Johnson and James
Baldwin and Tony Morrison and and so
many other writers so I'd like to think
of this book is being in conversation
with those books and I'd like to think
it's a bit primarily doing that kind of
work I teach to the University of
Vermont and I teach African American
Studies so I start I presume when I
started in the classroom I'm starting at
zero and you know teaching is that that
linear work we have to do and you start
here you get your students here but in
in when I when I am writing I can
meander and I can contradict myself and
ask questions that are and and reveal
things that are not conducive to that
linear work in the classroom but I liked
I think that they go hand in hand and so
what I think I leave out of my teaching
that vulnerability the ambivalence those
stories are here in the book and then
sort of vice versa
you know what's here in the book is not
necessarily going to appear in the
teaching I think that myself primarily
as an essayist you know we the book is
you know memoir and essays it wasn't my
idea honestly you know it was a the very
cold I of publishing the idea that you
know memo
have this sort of life now and there's
some certain on my editor's part that if
the word essays might actually be not be
more is that it was not as warm and I
guess I inviting a story so that's why
we have them here but I think if I think
that these essays is doing you know each
one doing a kind of discrete job
although they are obviously together and
United together I included an essay an
essay that that is not in the book as an
essay called fired and I like the essay
I wrote it I can't remember it was two
thousand six or seven I think it was
published in 2007 and it was about the
breakup of a friendship I decided not to
include it in the book because it gets
back to Nancy's you know word that's the
kind of larger issue of writing about
other people but at the time I wrote the
essay I didn't think I didn't write it
with malice in my heart but I didn't
write it with I think the same sense of
purpose that I have now an understanding
of what my goal is you know here to do
this kind of work when I published it I
got a letter a publishing of the
American scholar and I got an email from
a man who wrote me and said I hope you
will feel free to answer this question
if you had to do it again or rather if
you could choose the essay or the
friendship which would you choose and at
the time I mean I thought about it but I
said the essay and you know there's
certainly a lot of writers who feel that
way you know story first and I respect
that but for me that feeling of that
caval has changed you know from those
early years so I didn't include it
because I felt this book was unified and
around a vision I have developed since I
wrote that essay so I left it out
I wanted it to make sense and to go here
you know and to take hopefully the
reader on a journey through not only
different stories but moods and you know
different tempos and that book fell
outside of that larger goal you know to
give that that variety of experience it
felt out of the picture I was trying to
paint so there were there was a I think
there was I was very consciously shaping
that not only the essays but even she's
read the book but the essays too and
when I said earlier that I think a lot
about the shape of the story my essay
teaching the n-word I wrote it
deliberately against you know they kind
of mandate that happens as an educator
to to give people and a straight answer
you know don't use that word you know I
wanted to again I wanted to sort of
follow and generally some kind of
ambivalent trail and think about the
implications of the word and present a
series of scenarios and questions and in
my mind the gaps in that essay are kind
of invitations for a writer to enter
reader and kind of invent and and supply
some of his or her own the fodder there
you understand what I'm saying
so the it's meant to be porous in that
way so a lot of the things I left out
we're about trying to leave room for the
reader you know what did this book to
feel participatory I wanted it feel like
a friend and and like something you
could confide in you know as a breathing
entity I wanted it to be a compassionate
and a good listener you know as much as
it was about the stories it was holding
so in order to do that and to provide
that that feeling that has helped me so
much you know and inform my own taste in
reading I thought about that with
with the shaping of all of the different
essays you know and how to leave room
for the readers own experience you know
what I'm saying not to lock down a
question but to open it up and that
really motivated me a lot as I was
working so thank you I like that
question because it really is about what
is left out down to the you know down to
the gaps in paragraphs yes and also
thank you very much especially reading
it with your voice very particularly
powerful this is sort of related to the
idea what it's left out but in the sense
that we are democracy in America my own
question is always kind of come down to
especially since this is such a long
term project from 2001
how did conceptualizing up this change
with or did it change with politics
obviously but also you know thinking
about all these aspects of the way
nature Academy whether it has changed or
the ownership of an area did the
ownership nomenclature all these and
aspects and I can only imagine what
you're writing in 2001 and what comes
out published in 2019 a very different
time period see television you know what
was going on and what would the crises
to me and what I thought my own identity
was and 18 years later I'm a completely
different person with a completely
different understanding admit that he
and story and situation yeah I like that
and there you find that you're totally
from person but also fine totally the
same well the things I loved the I got
to loved getting to know Carl Van
Vechten when I was you know working on
him and he said that at 81 he said I
look in the mirror and I'm the exact
same person I was 18 and I get closer
God willing you know I think that's so
true for me as well so that changing
same that Baraka it applies to our lives
as much as music
I mean I've you're right I mean a whole
you know writing life
writing self-developed and those you
know in those years in terms of politics
you know I never felt more urgency about
the need to do the work I don't know
about those of you who are writers you
know we have things to say before you
know before things before who knows
what's next so I feel that urgency and
my classrooms I tell my students you
know what we're doing now is we're
practicing good citizenship that's what
we need now I think that in this world
you know I I want I need I suffer from a
lack of nuance you know when we are the
consuming the world around us you know
we're where are where the muted gray
areas you know where can we think
through something in beautiful ways and
so I feel that urgency even more I also
you know as it gets in these desperate
times what do I believe and I believe in
narrative I believe in storytelling
I believe in testimony I think that it
has transformative powers I've seen it
in my classrooms when the students can
tell the stories of their lives in ways
that where they see the connections to
in the cells and other people they're
liberated so a new urgency certainly
ideas that what are the stories that are
not being told that need to be
represented I think as images of
blackness as black people our bodies are
being used as pinatas it's possible to
consume images of people being killed I
mean in fact that's not shocking at all
to us anymore have this happen what is
the corrective and I think we dignify
each other by allowing
our the layers to flourish what I hear I
you know the story recently um wasn't
that long ago the woman who was the side
of the road and a cavity search was
conducted on her body without her
permission and I thought and what to
give her the throne of language and a
story because to be reduced to that
incident and a police report you know
that's how we dignify each other and
give each other I think our access to
our full humanity you know so I believe
this with more passion than I ever have
and it's the only way I know how to cope
with this political environment is to
talk back you know to talk back with
with with honest work and frankly the
mission right now is to be part of the
project of dignifying black lives you
know with narrative so that's I have a
small sense of that mission now you know
as all I have all I have to offer yes
that's very interesting I absolutely I
mean everything you're saying is you
know yes I agree with you I'll sleep
through the first part that um you know
if anybody had died at the result this
crime I think the story would have
changed I don't know that would be here
I don't know if it'd been possible for
me to talk about in the way that I do
you know and it's also true that other
other people who were you know survived
that incident however affected very
differently you know this is my own
version of this story I'll tell you
another story that's in the book in
terms of race and violence and
representation as I say in this in the
essay it's it's the hardest part of that
essay for me and the hardest part of
that experience was what happened with
the surgeon after and I tailed this
story it was the hardest part of the
book to write but the first surgeon who
was with me that night when I was lying
on the gurney and completely terrified
in the wool dirt walked up and without
saying anything to me or looking at me
he plunged his fingers into my open
wound and when I grabbed his arm
instinctively he said don't touch my
hand I was more terrified at that moment
than I was by the man who stabbed me and
so I think my if you say yes compassion
I mean you know there's mental illness
my family you know it's just
it's hard to disconnect that you know
it's this front from what he was
experienced a--to tional eyes too early
because he was you know because of
Ronald Reagan you know so I mean there
the history it's it's impossible to see
I think separate from that context but
certainly as I was on that on that
gurney what I understood immediately you
know through the haze of drugs was that
this surgeon saw this black body and the
gurney who is a victim of a gun of a
knife wound and made a lot of
assumptions about my value and how to
treat me you know so I mean it's a
reality many of us live with and every
time I'm back in the hospital I always
have to make sure and I'll say to sir
you know I have you read it these
studies that you know suggest that you
know this MiG's myths that black people
own experience pain in the same way and
I always make sure I have to make sure
so that to me was it was a moment that
was I never felt that terror and that
powerlessness and realizing this person
is not even seeing me at all and right
if it was a very different experience
and looking into the eyes of someone who
was just not home I know that if if the
look we'd exchanged had been one of
knowing it would have been a different
experience and admit it it's always more
terrifying to see someone who was just
not present but it also again made it
something that was deeply and impersonal
sometimes if I'm in New Haven I think I
mean is he am I gonna run into him you
know that would be very strange if I'm
ready for that but I think that's right
before I wrote the part about the doctor
I had to I had to do I had to research
find out where he was and I had to write
him a letter you know tell him what he
did and the impact of that and whether
or not he ever received it I don't know
but I hope it at least ruined his day
and maybe be a little education to pass
on but you know I think I've been that
experience
because it keeps revisiting me so I've
had to consider it from so many
different angles it was something that I
had to lay claim to in some way and
again write about in a way that that
gave me the authority you know his story
ended that night but then I've had to
live with it my own way and make sense
of it you know I think this book was
about learning to work with those within
that with those wounds the way I think
as black people we have had to you know
make this American experience something
meaningful so that's what that essay is
done and why it plays such a central
role in this book really but thank you
I'm not sure if I answered the question
but I love that supposition and yes
[Music]
well I'm very fortunate to teach at a
university I I get to pretty much pick
what I want to teach so I don't have to
I can be creative and I can be I can
take risks and teach new things I don't
have to work within really strict
parameters in terms of the courses I can
offer so I taught a class for instance
this fall called James and Joan the
American essay and they you know we were
just sort of making it up as we went
along and you know as a work in progress
kind of situation in terms of you know
everything that I teach comes out of the
love of the books like the you know the
loves of books that have meant so much
to me so it's very personal but in
teaching the N word in the essay I write
about that struggle I teach again at a
place where it's less and less true but
in my years at the University of Vermont
I've had I've had students white
students who never interacted with a
black adult before and so you know I
mean that kind of question of
representation is unavoidable you know
and I in order to live there I've
learned to embrace the mission of you
know transforming and educating my white
students I have I have our demographics
are changing but that has been the
history of my experience there but I
also struggle with them you know not
wanting the classes you know to be too
much about my experience right as the
black adult that they are first
encountering you know it informs the
things I teach but I do believe you know
the
the experience of the classroom should
happen between students so it's a it's a
it's a balancing act that I'm always
revisiting I think all of us who are
teaching at universities where we occupy
you know a unique have a unique kind of
status it's a always balancing I think
how much of ourselves we give to that
experience and how much do we let the
books carry you know carry the students
through so just it's so it's something
it's a good great you know it brings you
right into these big questions about
teaching right and and how much do our
for ourselves do we owe our students
something I'm still wrestling with yes
talk about your experience are you
involving into writing in expressing
that it's a particular black experience
that it there's it's a black experience
that really happens in mostly white
spaces and in particular class and group
of people is that something that you
both didn't want to get into in this
well you know um I don't know I think
that you know the book ultimately
belongs to the readers and and how it is
I think we have to live to write
honestly from our own experiences and
then let it go and how a reader chooses
to interpret that experience is belongs
to that person so I can only write from
the particular of my own experience but
in terms of trying to manage a readers
you know a reader's vision it's not
something I'm interested in doing you
know once it's out there then again the
thing that motivates me is a sense of
utility you know is a story useful and
can it have be productive in the life of
a reader and that's what I'm ultimately
that's what motivates me and that's
where my responsibility ends so in terms
of the specifics of class and everything
else
absolutely it's in there and the book
you know what I hope for it is to become
part of the conversation you know not an
entire conversation I would I don't
think any book can carry that and I
would be suspicious of any book that was
trying to carry that and I don't
particularly want to read books that are
telling me how to how to respond I want
be free as a reader - to take what I
need and to make that meaningful for me
so right I mean those things are up to
the reader to decide how to use them but
my responsibility ends by when I when I
when I it's a great question I think
it's I think it's an everyday battle I
think I think we don't you feel called
to tell certain kinds of stories and
sometimes those are scary but sometimes
that fear is the evidence that that's a
story you need to tell you know I would
never want to again thinking about
having to make peace with a kind of
artist that you are and I'm not someone
who's interested in pleasing you know or
conforming to a very standard kind of
narrative that doesn't interest me and
but I think that sometimes that can you
know you create a lot of anxiety you
know because we want to be accepted and
we want to be known right this great
line you know when there are watching
God when Janie's in the courtroom and
says it wasn't death she feared but
misunderstanding but I think that the
making the work is all about confronting
that you know and doing the scary thing
I think it honestly is just - keeping
your hand moving and staying committed
to the process and the more you do it
the more you'll do it and the freer you
will be but I think sometime those
things that are scary that make you
doubt yourself or the very things that
that's the invitation you know and
that's how you I think I can only speak
for myself how I grow as a writer
you know to take on those things that
are uncomfortable and might risk you
know it could have an interesting impact
I have to tell you story I said I was
giving a talk in them San Diego and
there was a man he was a faculty member
and we all went up for dinner afterward
and I could tell you know can tell if
someone's sort of aware of you but
they're not quite looking at you so that
it's okay this somebody's coming here
anyway sitting down he made a big show
of having a couple of cocktails and he
said you know what to be able to speak
freely and then he said to me you know I
protect my pain and he said so to me
your writing was pornographic but it was
interesting because he really needed to
say this to me but then he didn't want
to engage I mean I was surprised but now
of course I'm thinking how am I to use
this and that's something writing
because it's interesting isn't it but I
thought about how it's not the first
time you know I've gotten that kind of
response from from what I've written and
it is on some settling you know it's
unsettling when you are suddenly could
realizing someone has read your book in
a way that you and that you didn't
imagine but again that that that the
longing that is human to be safe and two
is not enough to keep me working you
know so I think we have to confront
those things in ourselves you know and
decide what is the larger mission and
then there's a daily practice after that
that's all I have to yes
[Music]
well you know um there are I feel like
I'm a pretty slow writer you know
they're pieces that I wrote these essays
that work sitting in a file for 10 years
I start having an essay about getting
married to my husband interstates and
the scene that that essay opens with
I've been struggling with it for 10
years before I was able to really work
into an essay was and I was astonished
my oh my god but even with me I couldn't
it didn't leave me but I didn't know how
to make it work so it took a long time
so the essays started like that with
these pieces and these moments that then
got built it's um you know I think my
husband always says books are books are
never finished just abandoned and so the
I think there's some point okay enough
once I felt I had a story that was right
had its shape but there there are so
many other moments I think that you know
how do we how do you make those
decisions you know that I think have to
follow the story and then everything
else kind of falls away when you have a
sense of what the what the threat is and
the path is but write these essays grew
up in all over each other and I had to
be deleted out and I had to you know be
coaxed into existence but it there there
are some that took many drafts and some
that sort of I knew it was happening
beforehand but I would say yeah it's
just it was about finding out were these
because they belonged thank you thanks
everybody thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]